[Ukraїner
Національні спільноти]
Коли я був маленьким хлопчиком,
[Київ,
Наддніпрянщина]
я народився ще за часів Радянського Союзу,
я дуже соромився того, що я — єврей.
Мене в школі обзивали: там «жидьонок».
І перший раз, коли я почув це слово,
я прийшов до мами і запитую: «Що таке жид?»
[Олександр Духовний — головний рабин Києва і України громад прогресивного юдаїзму]
Мати каже: «Ти це слово не вживай,
але ти — єврей, і колись настане час, коли ти будеш пишатися».
Коли я закінчив школу,
у мене всі найвищі оцінки в атестаті,
медаль мені не дали,
бо в паспорті в мене вже було написано «єврей».
В університет поступити я не міг,
навіть документи не взяли
в університет ім. Т.Г. Шевченка,
бо я — єврей.
Я вчився в Лондоні,
закінчив Лондонський університет,
і міг залишитися в Лондоні, бо моя дружина там працювала,
але для мене було дуже важливо повернутися в Україну.
Мій дідусь, який був рабином,
він був останнім, якого вбили під час Другої світової війни.
А я повернувся назад,
і той розірваний ланцюжок єврейської традиції мені вдалося з'єднати.
Перший елемент такої єврейської ідентичності я отримав від свого батька,
ще коли був малий.
Батько мене повів у синагогу,
мені було тоді сім років.
Я завжди знав, що я — єврей,
ніяких інших опцій не було.
[Йосиф Зісельс — голова Асоціації єврейських організацій та общин України]
Був дисидентом і політв'язнем у 70-80-ті роки.
А потім, коли почав, на щастя, розвалюватися Радянський Союз,
я почав більш активно займатися відновленням єврейського життя.
Ми створили у 1988 році першу громадську єврейську організацію в Україні.
Я дуже люблю своє місто, я виріс тут,
все моє життя пройшло тут.
Я закінчив школу на Андріївському узвозі,
там довкола було чимало місць для прогулювання уроків.
[Арсеній Фінберг
засновник проєкту «Цікавий Київ»]
Я завжди любив шукати якісь незвичні місця,
і саме з любові до цих незвичних місць і з'явився екскурсійний проєкт.
Основною метою нашого проєкту вважаємо те, щоб закохати якомога більше людей у наше місто.
У нас є близько п'яти різних екскурсій єврейським Києвом у різних районах міста.
Також ми створили аудіотур,
і зараз будь-хто, за допомогою смартфону в офіційному туристичному додатку міста Києва,
може послухати екскурсії з історії Бабиного Яру.
[Бабин Яр]
Це був якраз останній шлях більшості євреїв, які були розстріляні в Бабиному Ярі.
Переважна більшість розстрілів була за «Менорою», ми туди дійдемо, в ярах.
Цим шляхом євреїв, відповідно, вели.
З одного боку цих ярів євреїв виставляли лініями,
з іншого боку стояли кулеметники, які розстрілювали.
Люди просто падали в ці яри, їх вже штабелями складали знизу.
За єврейською традицією на цвинтарі залишають камінчики,
тобто приносиш, говорячи про те, що ти пам'ятаєш про тих людей, які тут лежать.
Я залишу, з вашого дозволу.
У липні 1942 року маму, її молодшу сестру, її брата, і її маму повели на розстріл.
І по дорозі моя мати, вона була старша у своїй родині, сказала своїй мамі:
«Мамо, я так хочу жити!»
Її мати сказала:
«Я буду за тебе жертвою до Бога»
Моя мати каже, що вона впала у вигрібну яму,
і не знаю скільки вона там пролежала,
а вночі їй вдалося вибратися з тієї ями,
і вона побачила свою молодшу сестру Броню,
вона теж сховалася.
Вони не знали куди йти,
і назустріч їм ішла мешканка сусіднього села і сказала:
«Дівчата, вам треба іти в Жмеринку».
А Жмеринка тоді була під румунами,
були чутки, що там євреїв не вбивають, а примушують працювати.
Я кажу: «Мамо, як же ви могли піти в Жмеринку? Могли ж дізнатися, що ви єврейки».
А мама каже: «Ні, нас не впізнали».
Я кажу: «Як?»
«Ми видали себе за українок».
Я кажу: «Як ви могли видати себе за українок?»
І мати каже: «Бо ми знали українську мову. Мова врятувала нам життя!»
І коли я тут в Києві навчався в російськомовній школі,
і дізнався, що я — єврей — можу не вивчати мову!
Мати сказала: «Ти живеш в Україні. Вчи мову».
Я дуже вдячний мамі за ту настанову.
Я люблю українську мову.
Не дуже часто доводиться спілкуватися, на жаль, тут у Києві,
але коли я змога, я завжди намагаюся спілкуватися українською мовою,
бо для мене мова — це і пам'ять про мою маму.
[Поділ]
Поділ став єврейським ще 1000 років тому,
бо тут були Жидівські ворота.
У старому Києві, коли був огороджений стіною з різними воротами,
саме в районі Подолу були Жидівські ворота.
Вони просто не збереглися зараз.
Було сім великих громад.
Тобто було сім синагог, навколо яких жили ці євреї і якими користувалися.
Деякі синагоги були професійні.
Наприклад, була синагога кравців.
Але обов'язково повинна бути синагога, в яку ти не ходиш.
Це анекдот такий є.
[Київська велика хоральна синагога (Подільська синагога)]
З вашого дозволу я одягну кіпу.
У мене на голові кіпа.
І, зазвичай, у хлопців є традиція покривати голову.
Релігійні євреї взагалі не знімають кіпу,
я намагаюсь одягати або в синагозі, або на цвинтарі, ну в найбільш таких місцях.
Сама Тора зберігається в Арон Га-кодеш.
Ну і відповідно, це місце, куди виходить рабин або кантор,
тому що більшість єврейських молитов співаються,
і звідси він зазвичай веде службу.
Я дуже люблю цю синагогу,
вона мені особисто є більш близька,
тому що з дитинства, так чи інакше, ходив сюди на великі свята.
Моя мати завжди мені казала: «У суботу працювати не можна».
І в нашій єврейській родині дотримувалися традицій.
Шабат означає відпочинок від творчої праці:
не можна будувати, не можна пахати, не можна написати дві букви поруч,
тобто не можна писати, не можна малювати.
І служби в п'ятницю ввечері, коли заходить шабат, і у суботу вранці — різні.
Служба не повинна бути одноманітною.
Більшість євреїв — нерелігійна  .
Тільки не кажіть про це рабинам, вони вважають, що всі релігійні.
Наприклад, я відчуваю потребу на свято піти в синагогу.
У суботу я не відчуваю такої потреби,
бо я працюю без вихідних, без свят.
Я не думаю, що є більше п'яти-шести тисяч релігійних людей.
Хто дбає про суботу, хто молиться, харчується кошерно, їх небагато.
І вони, у свою чергу, розділені на різні субконфесіональні напрямки:
є ортодоксальні напрями, є реформістські, є консервативні в єврейському середовищі.
Для того, щоб зрозуміти різницю, розкажу вам анекдот.
Кажуть, що на ортодоксальному весіллі вагітною буде мама нареченої,
на консервативному — вагітною буде наречена, а на реформістському — вагітним буде рабин,
тому що реформістський іудаїзм дозволяє жінці також бути рабином.
Це моє життя, і воно відбулося тут,
мені ніколи не хотілося поїхати.
Я себе ототожнюю з Україною,
це, так би мовити, форма моєї ідентичності — українська,
але середина моя, ядро — єврейське.
Я ніколи не стану справжнім українцем,
і не треба,
але українським євреєм, мені здається, я вже став.
Незалежна Україна зробила нас дійсно незалежними.
Мені здається, що Україна зараз навчилася як боротися і з антисемитизмом,
і з расизмом, і ксенофобією.
Ми сприймаємо різноманіття.
І Україна — це як той віночок із квітів:
вони — різні, але вони всі об'єднані.
І той віночок із кольоровими стрічками — це символ України.
От різноманіття в Україні, і єдність!
Ми всі поєднуємося в той віночок — це і є Україна!
[Єврейська спільнота —  одна з найдавніших, що мешкає на території України.]
[Її кількість почала стрімко зростати ще за часів Київської Русі.]
[Сучасні українські євреї переважно є нащадками одного із найчисленніших єврейських субетносів — ашкеназі.]
[Зараз в Україні проживає приблизно 300 тисяч осіб з єврейський корінням.]
[Повноцінне відновлення єврейської спільноти після концтаборів,]
[масових розстрілів та війн почалося вже із розпадом Радянського Союзу.]
[Колись на території України діяло до 800 синагог]
[Зараз їх лишилося близько 70 та їх активно відновлюють.]
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Режисерка монтажу
Марія Теребус]
[Оператори
Марія Теребус, Максим Мацюк, Анна Воробйова, Михайло Шелест, Олександр Заболотний]
[Журналістки
Валерія Діденко, Каріна Пілюгіна]
[Субтитрувальниця
Оля Стулій]
[Ukraїner
Національні спільноти]
[Серія відео створена за підтримки Агентства США з міжнародного розвитку (USAID)]